each year on December 10th worshipers
convene in Scandinavia to commemorate
the passing of an international arms
dealer once known as the merchant of
death Alfred Nobel and doubt a prize for
the ages a way of rewarding and
encouraging scientists to make
discoveries for the benefit of mankind
300 years before the first Nobel Prize
Galileo Galilei opened up a new window
on the cosmos when he first turned a
small telescope up to the sky Galileo's
observations shook up the world
overthrowing the paradigm that the earth
was the center of the universe but
brilliant as he was even Galileo had his
own share of astronomical blunders he
misunderstood the reasons why the ocean
has tides and even claimed the Pleiades
were a pure assembly of stars and stars
alone when in reality dust makes up much
of this beautiful cluster recently the
LIGO experiment has opened a window into
the cosmos every bit as revolutionary as
Galileo's I go is the first of a new
kind of telescope a telescope that
listens to the cosmos in September 2015
LIGO detected the ripples in space-time
from the merger of two black holes these
gravitational waves that reversed the
cosmos were more than million years this
detection earned Nobel prizes at least
for three of Lycos leaders for the first
time astronomers hadn't merely seen
something using visible light but rather
gravitational waves minuscule ripples in
space-time resulting from some of the
biggest fireworks in the cosmos black
holes are invisible that's how they got
their name after all so to the beginning
of time is also invisible to our
instead the oldest light that
astronomers can use to study the cosmos
is called the Cosmic Microwave
Background the CMB the CMB is a constant
glow of microwaves that envelop us and
is the leftover thermal heat from when
the universe was a mere 380,000 years
old embedded within this cosmic glow
mail-id the imprint of something much
older primordial waves of gravity from
inflation which is theorized to occur
just a split second after the Big Bang
years before the LIGO discovery
scientists speculated that the earth of
the universe would be like witnessing a
sort of black hole in Reverse with all
the mass the entire universe bursting
forth in a microscopic flash of time
this violent eruption would have
released a tremendous amount of
gravitational wave energy and these
waves could still be visible today in
2005 my colleagues and I set out to
detect these disturbances in the fabric
of space-time by observing their imprint
on the ancient Cosmic Microwave
Background we did so from the coldest
darkest place on earth the South Pole
Antarctica using the bicep2 telescope
then in 2014 after observing for nearly
a decade the bicep2 team shocked the
world with our claim that we had
detected these long sought-after signals
that we had witnessed the spark that
ignited the Big Bang the world erupted
in applause and whispers of a nobel
prize abounded as well but there are
other forms of signals imposters that
can mimic the signals from inflation
these signals come from dust clouds not
in the cosmos but in our own Milky Way
galaxy these dusty mirages have vexed
astronomers for centuries and indeed
cause Galileo to make one of his very
few mistakes soon after our announcement
rumors began to spread that bicep2 had
also been mistaken who is right had we
seen the birth of the universe or had we
liked Galileo in fooled merely seeing
what we wanted to see what role does the
Nobel Prize play in the motivations of
scientists today how does the Nobel
Prize fail to live up to
Alfred's lofty vision
losing the nobel prize tells my
insider's account of what it was like to
be a part of one of the most exciting
and controversial scientific discoveries
of the modern era